what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data data science
statistics and programming so subscribe
for all kinds of content just like this
if you haven't already and make sure you
hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is another video in my r
tutorial series
and the first videos of the series i
covered the packages dplyar
ggplot2 and tidyar these are some key
packages
out of the tidyverse which help you
wrangle a dataset into a nice clean
format
and then if you're using the ggplot2
package it's super easy to take that
data
and make clean pretty looking
visualizations
uh based on that data so a couple of the
other tutorials i did
after that cover uh base r functionality
as well as the various data types in r
now if you've seen my r tutorial number
four on all the data types
i do make a lot of mention of the fact
that dates and date times can be a
little bit tricky to work with
now that's where the lubridate uh
package is gonna come in handy
this is another package out of the tidy
verse and
anytime you're dealing with dates and
date times it is going to make your life
a whole lot
easier so we're going to cover some
various functionality out of it
namely creating date and daytime objects
in the first place
isolating the various components that
make up a date time
as well as the various time span classes
that is durations periods and intervals
so this script is going to be available
on my github repo
that's going to be linked in the
description of this video uh
just please note that some of the code
here
not as much as some of my earlier
tutorials but still a little bit
is adapted from the book r for data
science by hadley wickham and garrett
grolamund
highly recommend checking that book out
the link to that will be in this script
as well as in the
description of this video i'll also have
a link to a cheat sheet for lubridate
functions
as well as a couple helpful resources
which uh
will just break down some various
examples for the various lubridate
functions
so without further ado let's get started
so
two key functions that we're going to
start with here are the today function
and the now function let's start with
today
so i'm going to create an object called
day using the today function
then let's just look at the structure of
that
so this object day it's 20 20 09
22 that's the day that i'm recording
this video
and this is an object of class date not
much more to it than that
then if we use the now function again
i'm going to create an object called
date time
using this now function if we look at
the structure of that
we have the full date time that i ran
this chunk of code
it's 20 20 09 22 at 17
52 46 local time and this is an object
of class
posix ct so if you've seen my uh
tutorial on the data types in r
i mentioned that posix ct is one of the
most common
uh classes for date times in r basically
what a posix ct does
is it encodes the number of seconds
since an origin point
specifically that origin point is
1970-0101
at midnight in the utc time zone
so that's our two key classes for dates
and date times in
r just the date and the posix ct
now what i'm going to do next is i'm
going to create some character objects
then i'm going to convert those into
dates and date times
so if we go down here i'm going to
create two
objects string one and string two those
are going to be
20 20 09 22 something that just looks
like a date
but then 20 20 09 22 at
17 o'clock something that looks like a
date time
but when i run this code our defaults to
thinking these things are just character
objects
and that's fine now we're going to
convert
these things into dates and date times
there's a couple different ways to do
this
so in base r you do have these functions
as dot date and as dot posix ct
so for some people remembering as.posix
ct
and remembering you capitalize the posix
and don't the ct remembering that is not
something a lot of people necessarily
like to do
so lubridate makes this a little bit
easier
and more consistent we've got these new
helper functions
as underscore date and as underscore
date time
so i'm going to run all this code and
you can see the base r function as dot
date and the lubridate function
as underscore date return the exact same
thing
date objects and then as dot posix ct
and as underscore date time both return
20 20 09 22
17 o'clock but these are objects of
class posix ct
both of them so again it's ultimately
somewhat a matter of personal preference
but lubridate just makes this a little
bit more consistent and easier with
these functions
as underscore date and as underscore
date time
now as anybody who's worked with real
world date and date time data could tell
you
these things are not necessarily going
to be clean and they're not going to
necessarily be in
consistent formats so luckily luberdate
comes with some more helper functions
which no matter what the format
of our data actually look like when it
comes in as a character form but it's
really some kind of date or date time
there are different functions for
getting these in deposit ct
or date formats so let's look at some
different examples
so i'm gonna store the same uh
date in a variety of formats i've got 20
20 09 22 i've got 09-20
22-20-20
then i've got the way a lot of people in
europe will style this
today 22 slash the month 09
slash the year 2020 as well as some
various ways of
uh styling an actual date time so we've
got these various helper functions in
luberdate like
ymd that's year month date
mdy that's month date year
etc etc that tell r
let's look at this string let's look for
the year first
then the month then the date so on and
so forth you get the idea
and there are similar things for the
date time components
so let's say you have year month day and
then the hour
year month day the hour and the minute
or year
month day the hour the minute the second
which hopefully you'll have most of the
time
so let's look at all these examples
because they're all going to come
together very clearly
i use the ymd function for date format
one
i got the year the month the date got it
bam
then for date format two i had the month
then the day then the year so i use the
mdy
function bam for date format three i had
the day
followed by the month followed by the
year i used my handy dmy function
bam got to 2020 09 22.
now for this next date time i used
mdy that's month date y
underscore hms for the hour minute
second
bam and so on with the next example
year month date and then even though
this is formatted in a military
uh time kind of thing like 1700
uh ymd underscore hms gave me just the
date time that i wanted
now these things aren't 100 perfect
there are some
examples out there that can throw these
things off but by and large
these functions do a pretty good job so
just remember these functions whenever
you need to get whenever you're in a
situation where you've got some weird
formatted data
and you need to get it in a consistent
date or daytime format
and then also if you look up the help
documentation for any of these
like just do a question mark search for
uh ymd
underscore hms uh the documentation for
this is fantastic
and covers covers the majority of these
now of course once you actually get your
dates and your date times into the
format that you want
it'll happen all the time that we want
to do some kind of summary or some kind
of analytic
by the components of that date time so
we want to summarize something by year
or by month or by hour or
whatever the case may be any of these
various components
lubridate has a function for it so let's
take a look at all these
we're going to start by creating an
object and call it today date
that's going to be 2020 09 22 at the
time
1715 and let's just look at what
every single one of these functions
returns so the year function gives us
back
2020 obviously the month function is
going to give us back the number nine
the m day that stands for day of the
month
that's going to give us back uh the
number 22
then the hour function is going to give
us 17. the minute function is going to
give us 15.
the second function is going to give us
zero
then as for this y day function that's
pretty interesting
that's going to give us the numbered day
of the year
and it turns out this is the 266th
day of the year who would have known
right
then you also have this w day function
that's going to
return us back the day of the week now
today is tuesday
so that's day number three out of your
week because your week uh begins on
sunday so
sunday monday tuesday would be the third
day
so these are pretty straightforward with
a couple of these functions though like
month and w day you probably want the
actual
name of the month or the day in question
so in those instances just specify
label equals true as an argument to
these functions
and we're going to get the month is
september and the day of the week is
tuesday respectively
next i'm going to show a couple examples
in a more practical sense of where these
helper functions from lubridate
isolating the various date time
components are going to be helpful
and to do this i'm going to use the
flights data
if you've seen my first r tutorial
you're familiar with all this
the flights data frame comes in the nyc
flights 13 package uh it'll be freely
available for you to access
all i'm going to do is create a data
frame called data where i'm just
selecting three columns
flight carrier and most importantly time
underscore hour which is a posix ct
variable
so in my next chunk of code here i'm
going to create a new variable called
month just using the month function
where i'm specifying label equals true
all i want to do is create a bar chart
of the count of flights by month and
then
bam that was super easy right on the
x-axis i've got the various months
january through december and the count
on the y-axis
that was easy so next thing i'm going to
do is create a line plot for flights by
hour of the day
i'm going to do that by creating a new
variable and call it hour
just use the hour function obviously do
a group
by the new hour variable uh
and use the tally uh function to
to get the distinct count for each for
each hour and then
bam so now i have a line plot showing
the count of distinct flights
uh for each hour of the day turns out a
lot of people don't like flying between
the hours of like
midnight and five am i don't blame them
neither do i
then the last thing from the luber day
package which you should be familiar
with
are the various time span classes and
there's actually
three different classes of them there
are durations
periods and intervals so just to
give some definitions for these
durations measure the exact
number of seconds that occur between two
instances in time
a period measures the change in clock
time that occurs between two instance
these two seem very similar but you're
going to see where they're different in
a minute here
then intervals are kind of different
from the other two those are the full
time spans
representing a beginning and an end
point so
let's look at some examples here because
that's really going to illustrate these
things
so i'm going to create an object called
start date as well as an
end date and those are going to be the
beginning and end points of the month of
march 2020
so if i create a new object called diff
time
just let that be end date minus start
date
that's going to give me an object of the
diff time class
specifically it tells me it's a time
difference of 30.999 repeating days
so this diff time thing i'm going to
turn into a duration
as well as into a period so the duration
uh object tells us that it's two six
seven eight three nine nine seconds
i guess that's the number of seconds in
4.43 weeks or this many days
but this period object breaks it down
specifically as 30 days
23 hours 59 minutes and 59 seconds
so again there's an important
distinction here and you're gonna see it
in a little bit here
the interval uh object though that's
just
um that's just nothing to it but the
beginning point and the end point but
it's all kind of encapsulated into one
single object
now both durations and periods come with
various helper functions to them
and where these are going to be very
useful is whenever you need to modify
existing date times to add some unit of
time to them
let's say you need to add so and so
seconds to that date time
minutes whatever the case may be we've
got these helper functions d
seconds d minutes d hours etc etc
for durations but periods also have
similar helpful functions so we have
just seconds
minutes hours etc etc and those will all
work
too so let's take our start date which
was again the beginning of march 2020
and let's look at for instance d hours
five so we're adding five hours or
minutes that's the period helper
function for minutes
we're gonna add 300 minutes to our start
date
notice that both the duration helper
function
and the period helper function give us
the exact
same result so now i'm going to show you
a case where
these may not necessarily give you the
same result
so one thing which can really trip
r up with date times is daylight savings
time
so if we take the day uh 2020
0307 at midnight at
noon sorry so let's say we add one day
of time to that
using the two different approaches well
in this instance
we actually get two different results
and the reason for that is because
march 8 of 2020 that is the first day of
daylight savings time
and how it works is you just skip over
one of the hours
of that day so actually this day march 8
of 2020
that's a one day that only has 23 hours
in it
so how this works is this duration
function
d days is just going to add 24
hours or one day worth of seconds
to that original date time so you're
going to go all the way to
one o'clock the next day of 2020308 that
is
whereas with this day's function
that's just the human units of days and
when humans like you and i
tend to think of a day around daylight
savings time
we're not thinking of oh it's literally
24 hours or
24 hours worth of seconds we're just
thinking of the next day
at the same time so this is the key
uh instance in which the duration class
and the period class
could give you could give you different
results
so again daylight savings time that is a
common instance in which that can
trip you up if you're dealing with dates
and date times and r and you end up with
strange bizarre results just check that
you're not running into any kind of
daylight savings time kind of
kind of results now i'm sort of glossing
over intervals here because
just based on my own personal experience
i don't use them a whole lot
but they do have their own set of helper
functions like
in start and and int flip
just things like that such that if you
prefer to work using that class of data
your or
store your data that way you're able to
do so
now if you just search for the help
documentation here using like
question mark int underscore start all
the help documentation is pretty
thorough
and again it's pretty intuitive if you
choose to use these
so that covers the lubridate package now
this package as a member of the
tinyverse
probably doesn't have as much of a
learning curve and there's not as
much functionality to it as packages
like deploy r or ggplot2
but mark my words if a time comes when
you're dealing with
some messy data frame that's got weird
looking date times in it
this package is going to make your life
much easier so get familiar with
it before you have to so thanks all of
you for watching this tutorial
if you found it helpful please consider
sharing it otherwise at least consider
smashing the like button
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data